بدا بخلاف بسيط بين طلاب وطالبات احدى
المدارس في طرابلس شمال لبنان لكن تدريجيا
تطور الامر وتحول الى مشاجره عنيفه
بين الامهات الامهات منظر غريب جدا بصراحه
هذه الاسباب المتداوله لمقطع الشجار
الامهات الذي انتشر خلال الايام الماضيه
بالفعل كان ملفت جدا خصوصا وانه الامهات
يحملن اطفال رضع خلال هذه
المشاجره وهن قمنا بعضهن بعض ويتبادلنا
الضرب وشد الشعر مع مشاركه بعض الاطفال
محاولات من قبل الرجال الحاضرين لانهاء
هذا الشجار
لكن بالفعل هو يعني ما هي القصه
هذا العنف الشديد الذي اظهره الفيديو خاصه
وانه مشاركات جميعهن من النساء وهذا ما
سنعرفه من زميلتنارينا دويهي ايوه
صباح
[موسيقى]
الخشب للشعر وصراخ وهكذا فيديوهات عددا ما
تنتشر وتلقى دائما الكثير من التعليقات
ومن الانتقادات ولكن المفارقه هنا ان
الشجار الذي حصل في احدى مدارس مخيم
البداوي الى شمال من لبنان حصل بين امهات
يحملن اطفالا على اكتافهم اطفالا رضع على
اكتافهم ويتبادلن القتال بالايدي دون ان
يثنيهم ذلك صراخ الاطفال وهنا لب المشكله
يعني العنف على اشكاله له تاثير على الطفل
كيف اذا كان صادر عن شخص يمثل مثال اعلى
كالام يعني
هكذا تحلل مشكلات
المشاجره بدات ما بين الاطفال وانتقلت الى
اولياء امورهم وكما ترون في الفيديو
اصبحنا خارجات على السيطره كما اظهر
الفيديو وما اثار موجه من الغضب اتهم
خلالها المعلقون الامهات بعدم المسؤوليه
لتعريض اطفالهن للخطر المباشر
اسباب الفيديو لتزال يعني غير معلومه
ولكنها حصلت في حفل تخرج لاطفال الروضه
تخيل يعني فارياف يعني حصلت على احلى ذكرى
من حفل تخريجه الوقت هؤلاء الاطفال حصلوا
على يعني على ذكرى بشعه جدا يعني نقول في
الحياه الام مدرسه وفي المدرسه تاتي
التربيه قبل التعليم بعد الفيديو يضارب
المفهومين معا طب يعني ما ادري اذا جمال
يقول لي اذا عندنا وقت او لا
طيب انتهى انتهى الوقت ما كان بودي انا
اسالك لكن جمال كان مطنشني طيب من طرابلس
رينادويه شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
الغضب كله غضب الغضب الى اي احد يمكن ان
ياخذنا ليش يتحول دائما الى اعتداء جسدي
وهذا
التعبير امور سنناقش مع طبيب نفسي لكن قبل
ذلك خلونا نروح الى الزميل علاء سرحان
معلومات حول العنف عند الرجل وعند المراه
نعم على الرغم من ارتفاع معدلات الايذاء
الجسدي ضد الرجال الا انهم لا يزالون اكثر
استعدادا للعنف عن النساء في الولايات
المتحده مثلا تتعرض واحده من كل سبع نساء
للاصابه الجسديه الناتجه عن عنف شريكها في
مقابل رجل من كل خمسه وعشرين رجلا يبلغون
عن اصابه الدراسات تشير الى ان الرجال
اكثر ميلا لتوجيه الغضب الى
السيدات من اعتداء وعنف جسدي بينما تفضل
النساء العدوانيه غير المباشره مثل
الاضرار بالمكانه الاجتماعيه او نشر
الشائعات للاضرار بسمعه شخص ما بشكل عام
اظهرت دراسات حديثه ان الاعتداء الرقمي
اكثر شيوعا عند النساء ربما لانهن يشعرن
براحه اكبر عند اطلاق العنان لغضبهم على
الانترنت بالمقارنه مع العالم الحقيقي لكن
لماذا يميل الرجال لارتكاب العنف الجسدي
بشكل اكبر العلم يقول ان الاسباب قد تكون
جينيه او بيئيه مثل توارث مفاهيم مغلوطه
حول الرجوله والايمان بقيم مناهضه للنساء
هؤلاء من المرجح ان يتصرفوا بعنف تجاه من
هم اضعف منهم على كل حال سالنا الناس في
لبنان من الاكثر عنفا برايك النساء ام
الرجال ولماذا
واللي حسب تاريخ حسب يعني بدك رايك يعني
هي بنظر المراه اكثر من الجن عندها
[موسيقى]
مكان كمان بصير
معلومه كيف
المراه لانه اللي بتشوفه بالحياه بخليها
تصير عنيفه بس ببيتها لا بتكون عاقله
وادميه بس برا بس تطلع الطريق وتشوف الاشي
يلي ما حدا بيشوفها فبتضطر انه تكون عنيفه
مثلي انا مثلا في كثير ما حدا بيسترجي قرب
صوبه
لان ما بيقدر يرفض له طلبك تامر بشغله بده
ينفذها بالرب الرجل الرجل الاعمى معلومة
لا المره جوابك
اكيد الرجل يعني التسلط عنده يعني بلا بس
انه مش عالدرجه
معنا لا مشاهدينا اذا
الاستشاريه استشاري العلاج النفسي الدكتور
اسامه النعيمي
فش ولا اهدى منه يعني يا دكتور اسامه
دكتور شو رايك معقول للنساء اكثر عنفا من
الرجال
بطلنا كل المفاهيمنا بدهم يغيروا لنا
اياها
صباح الخير استاذه راويه وصباح الخير بس
استاذه راويه صباح الخير على العربي تمام
صباح الخير على
مشاهديكم
بس الرجال
على سلامته
اولا لازم نتفق على شيء الشيء الاول انه
اللهم اجعل كلامنا خفيف عليهم والشيء
الثاني اللهم طلعنا من دار البلا بلا بلا
اي سؤال انا جاهز طيب جاوبني على سؤالي
البراءه ليست اكثر عنفا من الرجل لازم
نعرف انه الانسان بالعاده هو مركب من
مجموعه المشاعر العواطف من جهه والعقل
والافكار من جهه ثانيه الا لما تصل
المرحله الى الغرائز عند الغرائز لا
المراه تكون اكثر عنفا لانه في هذه الحاله
تنسى قدراتها المحدوده تنسى وضعها
الاجتماعي تنسى خصوصيتها ككائن وتتحول الى
شيء مختلف جدا هذا ليس له علاقه بالبشر
بالضبط هذا ليس له علاقه فقط بالبشر
انظروا حتى الى مملكه الحيوان نفس الشيء
هذا هذا بودي اساله دكتور اتذكر حتى في
الحيوانات ربما يكون هو الاقوى الاشرس
الذي ربما يقدم لكن حينما يتعلق بسلامه
الابناء
وسلام والامان
الانثى تكون اشرس من الذكر لديها ربما
يعني منبه اقوى من الذكر ماذا عن الانسان
هي نفس الطريقه
يمكن هذه المشاجره اللي حدثت في لبنان
بسبب الابناء ولما يجي شيء لابنها تتحول
تخيل الامر وكانه العاطفه ترتفع فتصل الى
منصه معينه الى الى عتبه معينه بعد هذا
العاطفه تدخل الغريزه اول ما تحركت الام
هات تحركت خوفا على ابنائهم لكن كل ما زاد
الخوف تحول الى غضب كل ما تحول الغضب
ارتفع مستوى فقدوا قدرتهم على التمييز بين
اللائق وغير اللائق ويتدخلت الغريزه حمايه
للاطفال اولا ثم حمايه لانفسهم هذا لا
يعني انه ما حدث هو مقبول هذا هو مرفوض
حتى لو ما كان في اطفال هذا اللي كودات ان
اقوله انه يعني هذا حفل تخريج روضه مش ما
كانوش قاعدين في في الغابه وكان بواجههم
اسد مفترس ولا نمر شرس اطفال بيلعبوا مع
بعض يتشاجروا مع بعض هل تستدعي الامور
مثل هذه الحاله ومثل هذا الموقف انه غريزه
الام تتحرك لهذه الدرجه ليصل العنف
الى هذه الدرجه العاليه
هذا بالضبط اللي انا قلته انه لما ترتفع
العاطفه طبعا العاطفه هناك قد تكون مجرد
قد تكون الخوف اللي صار لكن معظم هؤلاء
النساء قد يكونوا تعرضوا الى الايذاء ممكن
تعرضوا الى التنمر ممكن تعرضوا الى ممكنهن
غاضبات او يشعرنا بضغط المجتمع حولهم
فكانت هذه الفرصه هي فرصه جاهزه للتنفيس
عن هذا الغضب اللي داخلهم طبعا لو سالتي
معظم هذول النساء سيبدو كثير من الندم على
الشيء اللي سووا لكن خلاص يعني يعني سبق
السيف والعزل بس هذه هذه دكتور النقطه انه
وياها رضيع والدافع عن ابنها يمكن لو كان
رجل كان فكر بانه اه لا ما بتستاهل انه
اطفال اولاد صغار
ويتخانقوا او ايا كان يمكن حل المشكله
اكثر بدبلوماسيه لكي لا يدخل في شجار قد
لا ينتهي لكن ما يتعلق بسلامه الابناء هنا
الام وصلت الى مرحله انفجرت لم تعد تفكر
لكن خلي في بالك هي شغلت الغريزتين هي
حافظت على الطفل اللي شايلته يعني لم
ترميه في الارض بحيث انه يضيع من عندها
وهذا جزء من الامومه في نفس الوقت دافعت
عن اطفالها الاخرين ثم اطلقت العنات
لغضبها اللي هو جزء من العواطف عشان تعبر
عن غضبها سواء كان هذا الغضب بسبب انه
الحادثه اللي صارت او لانه هي في داخلها
اشياء كثيره واجى الوقت انه يتنفذها ارجع
واقول كل ما حدث مرفوض من الجميع لكن اكيد
اكيد اكيد يعني شفت دكتور ليش نخاف منهم
ثلاث اربع انفعالات في وقت واحد اكيد تخاف
من الواحد يخاف منكم يقرب على غريزه على
الاطفال
استشاري العلاج بيضحكوا علينا يقول لك عيد
الاب والله ماكو احنا يوم واحد
دكتور
انا ما شايف انا ما شايف عادل انا ما شايف
شكرا شكرا دكتور اسامه
النعيمي على استشاري العلاج النفسي كنت
تبعنا الرياض يعطيك العافيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات